>>RIGHT NOW, NEARLY A DON
STATES HAVE PROPOSED LISLATION
THAT WOULD LIMIT OR BAN DRAG
SHOWS  FRONT OF CHILDREN, AND
THEY RANGE FROM LIMITING FROM
MINORS TO ATTENDING A DRAG SHOW
OR BARS OR PLACES THAT HOST THEM
TO OTHER BUSINESSES AND IN SOME
CASES GOING SO FAR AS TO
CHARGING PARENTS WHO CHOOSE TO
BRING THEIR CHILDREN TO A DRAG
SHOW STORY HOUR TO PREVENTING
THEM ON PUBLIC PROPERTY, AND THE
BILL IS NOT ANTI-DRAG, BUT PRO
CHILD, AND TO LIKEN IT TO KEEP
KIDS OUT OF STRIP CLUBS.
THIS IS A NEW TARGET IN THE
CULTURE WARS, AND THE REACTION
HAS TAKEN MANY BY SURPRISE.
A CHURCH HELD A DRAG BINGO EVENT
WHICH WAS A MONEY RAISING EVENT
FOR A UPCOMING TRIP.
>> WHILE IT IS NOT A POLITICAL
STATEMENT, IT IS IN KEEPING TO
BE AN OPEN AND AFFIRMING CHURCH
TO SEEK UNDERSTANDING AND LOVE
AND NOT THE JOIN OUR VOICES TO
THE CHORUS OF FEAR THAT SEEMS TO
ANIMATE SO MUCH OF THE NEGATIVE
RESPONSE TO THIS EVENT.
>> I AM JOINED BY REVEREND TODD
VETTER OF THE FIRST
CONGREGATIONAL CHURCH, AND ALSO,
JOHNATHAN WHO IS SOMEONE WHO
TAKES PART IN THE DRAG QUEEN
STORY HOUR.
JOHNATHAN, AS YOU HAVE TAKEN
PART OF THESE VENTS, AND WHAT IS
IT ABOUT THE DRAG PERFORMERS AND
THESE EVENTS, AND WHY ARE PEOPLE
SO THREATENED?
>> YEAH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY.
YOU KNOW, DRAG IS A FORM WHERE
THE ROOTS IN THE QUEER COMMUNITY
IS WHERE THE UPSET IS.
IF DRAG WAS SOMETHING ELSE,
PANTOMIME OR CLOWN, PEOPLE WOULD
NOT HAVE AN ISSUE, BUT I THINK
THAT IT STEMS FROM TRANSPHOBIA
OR HOMOPHOBIA, AND IT IS NOTHING
NEW, BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN IT FOR
YEARS.
>> AND IN ADDRESSING THE
CONGREGATION, PASTOR, YOU SAID
THAT YOU HAD NEVER WITNESSED
SUCH VENOMOUS LANGUAGE FROM
PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY ARE
CHRISTIANS, AND SO WHAT WERE
PEOPLE SO UPSET ABOUT WHEN IT
CAME TO THE BINGO EVENT?
>> WELL, ERICA, IT IS A
DIFFICULT WAY TO GET A CLEAR
RESPONSE, BECAUSE MOST OF THE
NEGATIVE RESPONSES WERE NOT
REASONED.
IT WAS AN EXPLOSION OF PASSION
AND FEELING, AND I THINK THAT
FOR REASONS THAT I THINK THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO EVERY INDIVIDUAL,
THERE'S JUST A DEEP THREAT
INHERENT HERE, AND JOHNATHAN'S
COMMENTS ARE WELL TAKEN.
I THINK THAT IT IS A SENSE THAT
PEOPLE ARE USING THE DRAG
PERFORMANCE AND THE DRAG
COMMUNITY AS SCAPEGOATS.
>> DO YOU THINK WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE EVENT, BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE
NEVER BEEN TO A DRAG STORY HOUR,
WHAT IS THAT EVENT LIKE?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, DRAG STORY HOUR
IS EXACTLY WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
IT IS DRAG STORY TELLERS WHO
READ CHILDREN'S BOOKS IN
LIBRARIES OR PLACES WHERE THERE
IS A STORY HOUR LIKE YOU HAVE
BEEN TO, BUT SOMEBODY WHO IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE FABULOUS
READING.
>> AND I LIKE THAT SOMEONE A
LITTLE MORE FABULOUS, AND AGAIN,
THIS EVENT FOR YOU, PASTOR, IT
WAS STANDING ROOM ONLY, AND FOR
A MISSION TRIP FOR YOUR YOUTH TO
REBUILD HOMES IN APPALACHIAN,
AND SO, THE BINGO EVENT WAS NOT
MEANT TO BE A LESSON, BUT IT IS
A VERY IMPORTANT LESSON FOR THE
CONGREGATION?
>> YES, I WANT TO SAY THAT THE
POSITIVE RESPONSE AND THE
GENEROSITY OF THE RESPONSE THAT
WE ENJOYED WITH THIS EVENT WAS
EXTRAORDINARY, AND IT IS UNLIKE
ANYTHING THAT I HAVE EVER
EXPERIENCED.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAD
TO TURN AWAY BECAUSE WE SIMPLY
REACHED CAPACITY WAS PROBABLY
ABOUT 150 OR 200, AND THEIR
GENEROSITY, AND THE PATIENCE OR
FORBEARANCE OF THEIR GENEROSITY
WAS EXTRAORDINARY.
SO I DO THINK THAT THE OVERALL
EXPERIENCE WAS EXTREMELY
POSITIVE.
IT WAS AN AFFIRMATION OF WHO WE
ARE AS A CHURCH, HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THE COMMANDMENT TO LOVE
OUR NEIGHBOR, AND I THINK IT,
WHATEVER LESSONS THE COMMUNITY
HAS TAKEN AWAY FROM THIS IS, I
THINK, POSITIVE, BUT IT IS A
GREAT AFFIRMATION FOR US OF WHO
WE ARE AND WHO WE ARE CALLED TO
BE.
>> AND IT IS CERTAINLY AN
IMPORTANT MOTIVATION FOR
CONVERSATION, AND CONVERSATION
SEEMS TO BE LACKING THESE DAYS
WHICH IS WHAT WE ARE STRIVING TO
DO WITH THIS CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING, AND I AM SURPRISED THAT
PARENTAL CHOICE IS ONE OF THE
RALLYING CRIES IN THIS VOICE,
AND THOSE ARE SOME OF THE VOICES
THAT ARE GOING TO CHARGE PEOPLE
TO COME TO A DRAG SHOW OR
PARENTS CLASSES, AND HOW DO YOU
SQUARE THEM AND MAKE SENSE OF
THIS MOMENT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS INTERESTING.
DRAG IS AN ART FORM, AND LIKE
ANY ART FORM, IT CAN BE
TAILOR-MADE TO ANY AGE OR
SPECIFIC GROUP OF PEOPLE.
BUT OUR ORGANIZATION IS A
CHILDREN LITERACY NONPROFIT
WHERE WE READ BOOKS TO INSTILL
INCLUSIVITY AND EQUITY AND
INCLUSION AND IT IS JUST
INTERESTING THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE
SO, YOU KNOW, PRO PARENTAL
RIGHTS ARE ACTUALLY STOPPING A
LOT OF PARENTS FROM ATTENDING
OUR TOTALLY OPTIONAL STORY HOUR.
WE ARE HERE TO BRIDGE
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER, AND WE
HAVE HAD LOTS OF EVENTS IN
AROUND NEW YORK AND AROUND THE
WORLD, AND A SURVIVOR OF
CONVERSION THERAPY, I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO BRIDGE THESE
COMMUNITIES WHERE OTHER QUEER
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HURT BY
CHRISTIA